this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
this week since we were so excited for
the mass effect legendary edition we
thought we'd show jonathan commander
shepard's tools of the trade from the
original trilogy
this the mantis m92c mantis
looks very much like a modern-day sniper
rifle with some
stuff stuck to it yeah it's a cool
design don't get me wrong but it does it
does smack of sniper rifle in space
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal army's museum and continue
to support jonathan's work check out the
links in the description of this video
right over to jonathan
the first weapon up is the avenger
can't we call it a rifle i don't think
technically speaking because from what i
understand of the
the law there's no rifle bore or
anything these are sort of
miniature coil guns or rail guns
propelling some sort of projectile at
some sort of velocity
uh in this case we've got uh chemical
rounds which you can always tell because
anything toxic in a game is always green
how that works with the mechanics of
reloading a weapon feeding a weapon
isn't clear because i'm familiar with
how
the projectile weapons are supposed to
work how that works with chemical rounds
how you
charge them with the chemical isn't
clear that might be in
in a codex somewhere i don't know i
guess that's one of the more
iconic designs from from this universe
it's
very sci-fi looking the two barrels some
squat humps looking design with a
somewhat recognizable butt stock
on it i mean fashion does affect the
design of firearms
no matter what anyone says the same
basic functionality can be obtained with
something that looks
completely different as far as the
aesthetics go so
some of what we see here it could well
be
purely down to aesthetic preference
we've got um essentially there a space
shotgun
and it fits that niche of a shotgun
that's pretty much described as such and
i always tend to think that
in the far future surely shotguns would
be obsolete there'd be a weapon that
does it all we wouldn't need something
that
is less precise has more of a spread
slower to reload but of course for
gameplay reasons you need a variety
of weapons and we've had the shotgun in
one form or another
for pretty much 500 years so
why wouldn't it still exist
something i'm struck by here is the the
sound effects
so the weapons are very sci-fi they look
they're hyper advanced they look like
something from
the future funnily enough the sound
effects though are very conventional
gunshot reports they sound like chemical
firearms going off
now to some extent that's expected i
would expect anything firing
a physical projectile even if it's a
tiny piece of hyper-accelerated whatever
i would still expect it to make a bang
it's a surprise in a way
aesthetically speaking that they went
with bangs
but i suspect things like aliens have
cemented and blade runner
have cemented the idea that if it's a
sci-fi weapon firing any kind of
projectile
or propelling any kind of projectile
with with force it's not an energy
weapon
that it will on some level go back
heavy weapons watch yourselves
uh we've moved to what's described as a
hand cannon here a sort of throwback
term here of hand cannon
implying that it's something that's low
rate of fire but very damaging
something equivalent to maybe a sawn off
shotgun or
maybe it's a space desert eagle we've
also moved here in mass effect 2
back to a more traditional ammunition
management system
from just being energy and heat based
to something i don't know if it's meant
to be more relatable more accessible to
uh players of other types of game maybe
given all the chest high walls in in
mass effect one they decided to go
um gears of war inspired i don't know
but you've got this standard count of
rounds in the magazine
number of magazines it looks to me as
though we've got some sort of
holographic technology
here acting as a sort of interface on
the outside of the weapon
and possibly as a sighting system
forgive my ignorance but um it looks
like there is some sort of
holographic site which no longer
requires a frame
or a tube or to be projected it just
appears on top of the weapon and i don't
think we're
that far away necessarily by which i
mean 50 years or so
from some sort of site that can just be
generated above the weapon
we are going to move away from the iron
sight i think
we've already reached the point where
firearms are sold without any iron
sights
right we've got the x9e tempest
submachine gun so again we've got um the
game mapping itself onto
current world tropes for firearms why
would you need a submachine gun
other than for gameplay reasons there is
no reason it really should be able to
do what the assault rifle has nearly
done in the current era which is make
the submachine gun obsolete
so same applies here to mass effect why
would you need something that is
essentially a giant pistol
um especially as it appears to have no
butt stock
and we know that the rifles require butt
stocks for accurate firing
this is much more of a gears of war
inexplicable missing stock situation why
wouldn't it have some sort of
shoulder stop
we've got the avenger here again for me
the one of the more iconic weapons of
the
of the franchise is someone who's not
really a player and it has
got i've i've criticized it for not
having
an optical sight but at least by mass
effect 2 the m8 has got some sort of
built-in optical sight on top of it
otherwise the design of the thing is is
really sci-fi it doesn't really look
like anything that we have today other
than having a pistol grip and a trigger
and a
recognizable butt stop but the
description is interesting because it
it's one of these game descriptions that
could have been written about
a mock day weapon modular design
inexpensive components favorite of
military groups and mercenaries
reputation for being tough reliable easy
to use easy to upgrade
that pretty much fits the ar15 and that
description kind of with that without
overtly comparing it to the present day
equivalent settles your brain into oh
yeah
it's like an m4 i want to be using that
as my stock go-to weapon probably
so one of the holographic things that
i'm seeing on the weapon here
is what i gather as a symbol for some
sort of incendiary ammunition
so it looks like um you could have had
that in the hud which is obviously what
the
we as a video game player is seeing but
it seems as though rather than a sort of
head-up display on neural interface
what in mass effect 2 anyway you see
what you need to
project it out of the weapon that's
something i've not seen done
in contrast to something like gears of
war whether we're glowing lights on the
weapon
because it looks cool this does
something functional
we are on to the machine guns s76c
revenant described as a machine gun and
it is big and bulky
to sort of fits that the reality of what
a machine gun is and also
the trope of being something big and uh
slows you down
but it's potentially more damaging so
i'm not quite sure if this is meant to
use different technology than the
assault rifle and other weapons but it
seems to be rather different that
they look like energy blasts and they're
traveling a lot slower than
i would imagine we've also got a muffled
report from the weapon
which i'm guessing is to do the fact
that we're in either no atmosphere
or a very thin atmosphere where sound
doesn't travel
well if there's no atmosphere it
wouldn't shouldn't travel at all
although you'd still
feel the vibration um and if the gun is
against your space suit you would get
sound conducted through the spacesuit
through the helmet through the whatever
but it's a
change in um changing report that i
don't think is reflective of the fact
it's a machine gun so much as the
environment that we're in
and then the sniper rifle class this the
mantis m92c
mantis looks very much like a modern-day
sniper rifle maybe an anti-materiel
rifle
with some stuff stuck to it which
to be fair to mass effect is not
normally the case the weapons are really
pretty creative
i think this falls into the we if it's a
sniper rifle it's gonna look like a
sniper rifle so it's got to have a big
thick barrel
some sort of muzzle device looking thing
on the end which i'm not sure you'd need
and then it's got a sort of integrated
electronic looking scope
yeah it's a cool design don't get me
wrong with some curves and everything
but it does
it does smack of sniper rifle in space
now the description for it claims that
it's used primarily by police and
militia groups
and of course police do have a
requirement for marksmans and
sniper rifles albeit they tend to use
them at much closer range for a very
accurate shot
at a range that would normally be like
an infantry rifle range hundred meters
two hundred
and probably no more than a hundred
meters i would have thought because you
absolutely must not
harm civilians and if you have to take a
shot to use lethal force it has to be
dead on whereas military snipers are
obviously trying to
incapacitate or kill at all sorts of
different
distances
and as we're moving up the destructive
spectrum
we've reached an actual anti-materiel
rifle
or as the game has it anti-material
rifle which is technically incorrect
and the x-98e widow this does look very
very science fiction it's but it has an
enormous scope on it i'm not really sure
why
we wouldn't miniaturize optical sight
technology
or even be using nano drones to
fly unseen to the target guided rounds
guided triggers
all sorts of technology you could
extrapolate to
do something other than just it's a
space barrett
this is a space barrett uh the
description kind of backs me up there
in that talks about how good it is
against armor and shields
the weight of 39 kilograms just why
would a future anti-materiel rifle need
to be 39 kilograms i don't understand
maybe it's because it gives you near
unlimited ammunition i don't know
just to further reinforce the trope of
not only the sniper rifle
in a game but the heavy sniper rifle or
anti-materiel rifle this thing is
single shot it might have an unlimited
magazine for i know but
between shots the operator has to charge
it
i cannot see a reason why that would be
necessary we've already reached the
point where
accurate semi-automatic sniper rifles
exist if you've got
the money that basically negate the need
for a bolt action and in the next 20 odd
years i dare say bolt actions will
shuffle off entirely
bit of a change of pace so we've got
something that's classified as a shotgun
but is not a shotgun it's not
a gun as far as i can tell and it
definitely doesn't fire shot
uh fires miniature but potent cluster
rounds of super conducting
projectiles i don't know that that makes
sense two-stage trigger system allows
for either quick fire capacitors or a
charge and release attack ah okay so
this is a this is a charge up and
release
alt fire type situation okay fair enough
so it's an alien shotgun
essentially or it's what they what
they've developed in parallel to our
real world shotgun which is then be
replaced by
the type of shotguns we see in mass
effect so i didn't see a huge difference
in the way the weapon was depicted um
for something that
seemed to be saying it was more of an
energy weapon and seemed to function
much the same
sounded a bit more a bit more pew pew
but in terms of its role in the game it
definitely
you can see why it's in the shotgun
bracket because it functions much like
one really
right the really big stuff so uh m100
grenade launcher
this is quite a funky looking thing big
chunky thing with a big drum
magazine given that most weapons in
these games seem to work
on the basis of accelerating fragments
of metal
i'm not quite sure how the grenade
launchers are supposed to function
in actual use the grenade launcher is
well it sort of makes sense as an
extrapolation of current
technology we've already seen things
like the xm25 that are
semi-automatic smaller grenades that
travel on a
flatter trajectory are they not as flat
as this this is more like a
sort of personal rocket launcher
actually the speed that the things
travel they travel on a flight
trajectory they look to be rocket
assisted
or in some way propelled plausible
enough for sort of far future grenade
launcher equivalent
no reason why we would have to be stuck
with an arcing trajectory
uh we've got another alien weapon now
the collector assault rifle so the term
assault rifle obviously
implies certain things but this this
race has used sort of uh
biomechanical technology which which
gives it a
rather different aesthetic probably the
most important thing about it actually
and it expresses some vagueness over how
it actually works which
which is nice you know you wouldn't
necessarily know how an alien weapon
functioned
so but it's interesting that it's
developed in exactly the same
parallel the description is very
reminiscent of the human assault rifle
so
uh pieces are pellets of metallic enamel
rather than just shavings of metal same
difference really
so it's it's this classic thing of you
must have parity in between your races
i suspect so that something in the same
bracket must be of equivalent power
interesting different reports which you
might expect from from a foreign
technology if you like
um seems to work on the reloading
principle of slap it like it owes you
money
not really sure what's going on there
we've got another collector weapon here
forgive my ignorance as to who the
collectors are but it's very
alien looking using focused radiation so
a particle beam
this is an energy weapon this is what
the franchise seems to avoid for the
most part
as it says in the description the amount
of energy needed to create a beam that
can damage something
is several orders of magnitude more than
what's necessary to accelerate a
projectile so it's
less plausible as a human sci-fi weapon
but of course if we introduce other
races other species if indeed that's
what's going on then that opens things
up a bit
kind of what i expected hoped for
something that is a constant being like
a
like a proton pack from ghostbusters but
more focused
something that you can hose on target so
you can also walk the beam onto target
beam weapons they're great fun
right so mass effect threes m96 matic
two now mata because i know from having
trained as an archaeologist
is a hand tool breaking up soil
so not it's an interesting choice of
name uh the aesthetic seems to have
shifted
slightly although it's recognizably mass
effect two sort of
barrel like protuberances with a casing
so it fits it fits the aesthetic and
we've clearly got now
in line with the tropes of the day the
ability to modify
the weapon not just change the ammo out
but to actually modify it and change its
stats
i definitely got the sense there of a
sort of sci-fi version of a
quote-unquote battle rifle something
more powerful but
slower firing
thank you for watching um please do look
at the links in the description
in case you'd like to donate or help us
out here at the royal armouries we
by the time you see this we will be open
again at two of our three sites so here
at leeds
down at fort nelson as well and
hopefully not in the not too distant
future
at the tower of london two otherwise
though we'll see you again next time
thanks again
[Music]
so
you